ENTIRE PLANT PLANET IS NOTHING
COMPARED TO THE COMFORT OF A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
ELIZABETH WARREN VERSUS THE
FIELD ISN'T THE ONLY BATTLE THAT
UNFOLDED LAST NIGHT.
THERE WAS TULSI GABBARD VERSUS
THE ENTIRE U.S. PRESS CORPS.
UNLIKE VIRTUALLY EVERYONE ELSE
IN HER PARTY, GABBARD BELIEVES
IN KEEPING AMERICA OUT OF
POINTLESS FOREIGN ENTITLEMENTS
AND FOR THAT BELIEF, SHE HAS
BEEN TARRED REPEATEDLY AND VERY
AGGRESSIVELY AS A FOREIGN AGENT.
LAST NIGHT SHE HIT BACK.
>> "NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN HAVE
ALSO SMEARED VETERANS LIKE
MYSELF FOR CALLING FOR AN END TO
THIS REGIME CHANGE WAR.
JUST TWO DAYS AGO,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PUT OUT AN
ARTICLE SAYING THAT I'M A
RUSSIAN ASSET AND A ASSAD
APOLOGIST AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT SMEARS.
THIS MORNING AND CNN
COMMENTATORS THAT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION THAT I AM AN ASSET OF
RUSSIA.
COMPLETELY DESPICABLE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
CNN DOESN'T CARE FOR HER EITHER.
WE KNOW THAT FOR A FACT BECAUSE
RECENT FOOTAGE FROM PROJECT
VERITAS SHOWS A CNN EMPLOYEE
CONCEDING THAT THE NETWORK IS
INSTITUTIONALLY HOSTILE TO
TULSI GABBARD.
WATCH THIS.
>> THINK THE ONE THEY DON'T
LIKE, THEY DON'T LIKE
TULSI GABBARD.
BECAUSE SHE SUPPORTS ASSAD AND
SHE'S NOT TAKING THE
CONVENTIONAL ROUTE WHEN IT COMES
TO FOREIGN POLICY.
SHE'S ACTUALLY PRETTY LIBERAL.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THAT ONE
POSITION.
>> Tucker:
CONGRESSWOMAN PELOSI GABBARD OF
HAWAII JOINS US.
CONGRESSWOMAN, YOU JUST HEARD
THAT, FINALLY FOUND THE ROAD.
THERE IS A CNN EMPLOYEE SAYING
THAT FOR TAKEN AND
UNCONVENTIONAL FOREIGN POLICY
POSITION, YOU ARE THE ONE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE THAT CNN
DOESN'T LIKE.
DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU?
>> IT DOESN'T.
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S KIND OF
ABSURD ACTUALLY THAT AS WE SAW
IN THE DAYS LEADING UP TO THE
DEBATE LAST NIGHT, BOTH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN
BOTH RAN HIT PIECES.
TODAY, THE DAY AFTER THE DEBATE,
WE SEE MORE OF THESE HIT PIECES
COMING OUT.
FOR THEM TO SIT THERE AND TRY TO
PORTRAY THEMSELVES AS NEUTRAL
ARBITERS, AS OBJECTIVE AND
INDEPENDENT ENTITIES WORKING
WITH THE DNC TO CARRY OUT A
LEGITIMATE DEBATE IS FRANKLY
JUST A JOKE.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I'VE
BEEN CALLING FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION LIKE THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS TO ACTUALLY HOST
THESE DEBATES IN A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY SERVES THE INTERESTS OF
VOTERS, NOT THE PROPHET, THE
PROPHET BEARING CORPORATE
INTERESTS OF THE CORPORATE
MEDIA.
>> Tucker: I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE.
SO JUST FOR OUR VIEWERS WHO
MAYBE HAVEN'T FOLLOWED THIS,
WHEN WE SAY YOU'VE BEEN ATTACKED
BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN,
IT'S NOT A TAX LIKE THEY ARE
SAYING YOUR HEALTH CARE PLAN IS
TOO EXPENSIVE.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT YOU ARE
WORKING FOR A FOREIGN POWER
AGAINST AMERICA'S INTERESTS,
THAT YOU ARE A TRAITOR TO THE
COUNTRY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE
ESSENTIALLY SAID THAT.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS
TO THOSE LIKE MYSELF WHO ARE
TRYING TO END THIS REGIME CHANGE
WAR IN SYRIA, WHO ARE CALLING
FOR AN END TO OUR COUNTRY'S
POLICY BEING THE WORLD POLICE,
BRING ABOUT AN END TO THESE
REGIME CHANGE WARS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
JUST HAPPENING TO ME.
YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY ARE ISSUING
THESE SMEAR ATTACKS, REALLY WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS SMEARING
ANYONE WHO IS CALLING FOR AN END
TO THESE REGIME CHANGE WARS,
INCLUDING VETERANS WHO I MEET
ALMOST EVERYTHING THE DAY ALL
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE NOT
PACIFISTS.
THEY UNDERSTAND AND KNOW
FIRSTHAND THE COST OF WAR AND
WHO ARE STRONGLY, STRONGLY
CALLING FOR OUR COUNTRY TO PUT
AN END TO THESE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE REGIME CHANGE
WARS.
SO WHEN THEY ARE ISSUING THESE
SMEARS AND CALLING ME A TRAITOR
TO MY COUNTRY, THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLY ISSUING THESE SMEARS
AND ATTACKS TO EVERY VETERAN WHO
HAS BEEN WILLING TO LAY THEIR
LIVES DOWN IN SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
MANY THINGS WE DON'T AGREE ON
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS I'M SO,
SO PATHETIC TO WHAT YOU AND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN THERE.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IT'S REAL.
THE ONE SUBJECT THEY WON'T
ACCEPT ANY DEVIATION ON.
SO YOU DESERVE CREDIT I THINK